so many of you have probably seen the
movie the Martian but for those of you
who did not it's a movie about an
astronaut who is stranded on Mars and
his efforts to stay alive until the
earth can send a rescue mission to bring
him back to earth gladly they do
reestablish communication with the
character astronaut Watney at some point
so that he's not as alone on Mars until
he can be rescued so while you're
watching the movie or even if you
haven't when you think about Mars you're
probably thinking about how far away it
is and how distant and what might not
have occurred to is what are the
logistics really like of working on
another planet of living on two planets
when there are people on the earth and
there are Rovers or people on Mars so
think about when you have friends
families and co-workers in California on
the west coast or in other parts of the
world when you're trying to communicate
with them one of the things you probably
first think about is like what time is
it in California will I wake some up is
it okay to call so even if you're
interacting with colleagues who are in
Europe you're immediately thinking about
what does it take to coordinate
communication when people are far away
so we don't have people on Mars right
now but we do have Rovers and actually
right now on curiosity it is 6:10 in the
morning so 6:10 in the morning on Mars
we have four Rovers on Mars the United
States has put four Rovers on Mars since
the mid-1990s and I have been privileged
enough to work on three of them so I am
a spacecraft engineer spacecraft
operations engineer at NASA's Jet
Propulsion Laboratory in Los Angeles
California and these Rovers are our
rogue
emissary's so they are our eyes and our
ears and they see the planet for us
until we can send people so we learn how
to operate on other planets through
these Rovers so before we send people we
send robots so the reason there is a
time difference on Mars right now from
the time that we're at is because the
Martian day is longer than the Earth Day
so our Earth Day is 24 hours because
that's how long it takes the earth to
rotate how long it takes to go around
once so our day is 24 hours it takes
Mars 24 hours and approximately 40
minutes to rotate once so that means
that the Martian day is 40 minutes
longer than the Earth Day so teams of
people who are operating the Rovers on
Mars like this one what we are doing is
we are living on earth but working on
Mars so we have to think as if we are
actually on Mars with the rover our job
the job of this team of which I'm a part
of is to send commands to the rover to
tell it what to do the next day to tell
it to drive or drill or tell her
whatever she's supposed to do so while
she's sleeping and the rover does sleep
at night because she needs to recharge
her batteries and she needs to be
weather the cold Martian night and so
she sleeps so while she fleets we work
on her program for the next day so I
work the Martian night shift
so in order to come to work on the earth
at the same time every day on Mars like
let's say I need to be at work at 5:00
p.m. this team needs to be at work at
5:00 p.m. Mars time every day then we
have to come into work on the earth 40
minutes later every day in order to stay
in sync with Mars so that's like moving
a time zone every day right so one day
you come in at 8:00 the next day 40
minutes later at 8:40 the next day 40
minutes later at 9:20 the next day at
10:00 so you keep moving 40 minutes
every day until soon you're coming to
work in the middle of the night the
middle of the Earth's night right so you
can imagine how confusing that is hence
the Mars watch this watch has been
mechanically the weights have been
mechanically adjusted so that it runs
more slowly right and we didn't start
out I got this watch in 2004 when Spirit
and Opportunity the the Rovers back then
we didn't start out thinking that we
were going to need Mars watches right we
thought okay we'll just have this time
on our on our computers and it on the
Mission Control screens and that would
be enough yeah not so much because we
weren't just working on Mars time we
were actually living on Mars time and we
got just instantaneously confused about
what time it was so you really needed
something on your wrist to tell you so
you could you know like okay what time
is it on air is what time is it on Mars
and it wasn't just the time on Mars that
was confusing we also needed to be able
to talk to each other about it so a fall
is a Martian day again 24 hours and 40
minutes so when we're talking about
something that's happening on the earth
we will say today so for Mars we say to
fall
right yesterday
became yester saw for Mars again we
didn't start out thinking oh let's
invent a language it was just very
confusing I remember somebody walked up
to me and said I would like to do this
activity on the vehicle tomorrow on the
rover and I said tomorrow tomorrow or
Mars tomorrow right we started this
terminology because we needed a way to
talk to each other
so tomorrow became next rasol or solaro
right because people have different
preferences for the words they use right
some of you might say soda and some of
you might say pump so we have people who
say next result or solaro
and then something that I noticed after
a few years of working on these missions
was that the people who work on the
Rovers we say to solve the people who
work on the land admissions that don't
Rove around they say to Seoul so I could
actually tell what mission you worked on
from your Martian sense so we have the
watches and the language and you're
detecting a theme here right so that we
don't get confused but even the Earth's
daylight could confuse us if you think
that right now you've come to work and
it's the middle of the Martian night and
there's light streaming in from the
windows that's going to be confusing as
well so you can see from this image of
the control room that all of the blinds
are down so that there is no light to
distract us the blinds went down all
over the building about a week before
landing and then they didn't go up till
we went off Mars time so this also works
for the house right for at home so I've
been on Mars time three times and my
husband is like okay and we're getting
ready for Mars time and so he'll put
foil all over the windows and we darken
you know dark curtains and shades
because it also affects your families
and and here so here I was living in
kind of this darkened environment but so
was he and he'd gotten used to it but
then I would get these printed
emails from him when he was at work
should I come home are you awake what
time is it on Mars and I said okay so he
needs a Mars watch but of course it's
2016 so there's an app for that so now
we get you know instead of the watches
we can also use our phone but the impact
on families was wasn't just across the
board it wasn't just those of us who
were working on the Rovers but our
families as well this is David oh one of
our flight directors and he's at the
beach in Los Angeles with his family at
1:00 in the morning
so because we landed in August and his
kids didn't have to go back to school
until September they actually went on to
Mars time with him for one month they
got up 40 minutes later every day and
they were on dad's work schedule so they
lived on Mars time for a month and had
these great adventures like going
bowling in the middle of the night or
going to the beach and one of the things
that we all discovered is you can get
anywhere in Los Angeles at 3:00 in the
morning when there is no terrific so we
would get off work and we instead of
going you know we didn't want to go home
and bother our families and we were
hungry so instead of going you know
locally to eat something we'd go wait
there's this great all-night deli in
Long Beach and we can get there in like
ten minutes so we would drive down it
was like the 60s right no traffic we
would drive down there and the
restaurant owners would go who are you
people and why are you at my restaurant
at 3:00 in the morning so they came to
realize that there were these packs of
Martian roaming the LA freeways in the
middle of the night and we in the middle
of the earth night and we did actually
start calling ourselves Martians and
every so those of us who are on Mars
time we would refer to ourselves as
Martians
and everyone else as earthlings and
that's because when you're choosing a
time zone every day you start to really
feel separated from everyone else you're
you're literally in your own world so I
have this button on that says I survived
Mars time Sol's 0 to 90 and there's a
picture of it up on the screen so the
reason we got these buttons is because
we work on Mars time in order to be as
efficient as possible with the rover on
Mars to make the best use of our time
but we don't stay on Mars time for more
than three to four months eventually
we'll move to a modified Mars time which
is what we're working now and that's
because it's hard on your bodies it's
hard on your families in fact there were
sleep researchers who actually were
studying us because it was so unusual
for humans to try to extend their day
and they had about 30 of us that they
would do sleep deprivation experiments
on them on us and so I would come in and
take the test and you know I fell asleep
in each one and that was because again
this was so eventually it becomes as
hard on your body even though it was a
blast right it was a huge bonding
experience with the other members on the
team but it is difficult to sustain
so these Rover missions are our first
steps out into the solar system we are
learning how to live on more than one
planet we are changing our perspective
to become multiplanetary so the next
time you see a Star Wars movie
and there are people going from the
Dagobah system to Tatooine think about
what it really means to have people
spread out so far what it means in terms
of the distances between them how they
will start to feel separate from each
other and just the logistics of the time
we have not sent people to Mars yet but
we hope to and between companies like
SpaceX and NASA and all of the
international space agencies of the
world we hope to do that in the next few
decades
so soon we will have people on Mars and
we truly will be multiplanetary and the
young boy or the young girl who are who
are the people who are will be going to
Mars could be in this audience or
listening today I have wanted to work at
JPL on these missions since I was 14
years old and I am privileged to be a
part of it and this is a remarkable time
in the space program and we are all in
this journey together so the next time
you think you don't have enough time in
your day just remember it's all a matter
of your earthly perspective thank you
[Applause]